بسبب حرائق كندا نيويورك تسجل اسوا تلوث
للهواء في العالم والخروج الى الهواء
الطلق ممنوع الا للضروره المطلقه بحسب
طبعا سلطات المدينه الامريكيه بعدما هب
مشاهدينا دخان دار جنوبا من اكثر من 100
حريق اتحدث هنا عن حرائق غابات مشتعله في
مدينه كبك بكندا ليسجل مؤشر جوده الهواء
في نيويورك اعلى من 200 عند نقطه محدده
ليله امس وهو مستوى غير صحي نهائيا في وقت
لاحق سجلت نيويورك ثاني اسوا مستويات تلوث
للهواء في العالم بعد ان يودالهي في الهند
ومن المدن الاخرى على القائمه كمدينه
بغداد في العراق وايضا له في باكستان
حفاظا على الامن الصحفي المدينه
الغت عشر مناطق تعليميه على الاقل في وسط
ولايه نيويورك الانشطه والفعاليات
الخارجيه ومن المتوقع ان يبقى الدخان في
المدينه الى اليومين المق وفي طلب كذلك
الذين امروا به عند انتشار كورونا طالبت
السلطات السكان بارتداء الاقنعه العاليه
الجوده مثل الان
19 ايضا في حال الخروج الى الهواء الطلق
يجب ارتداء هذه الاقنعه كما اجتاح
مشاهدينا الدخان المنبعث من حرائق كندا
بشكل دوري شمال شرقي ووسط المحيط الاطلسي
لاكثر من اسبوع مما اثار مخاوف بشان اضرار
استمرار داءت نوعيه الهواء هذا وكان
اندلاع اكثر من 400 حريق ضخم في جميع
انحاء كبك ودمرت هذه الحرائق ما في كندا
ما يقارب التسعه ملايين فدان هذا العام مع
حرق ما يقارب ايضا من نصف مليون فدان في
كبك وحدها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات